اكتفت برامج المرشحين وديتهم الانتخابيه
بالتركيز على تحسين الخدمات وتطوير مناطقم
الانتخابيه ولم تحضر القضايا الاقتصاديه
الرئيسيه واقتراح حلول لها بنصيب من
الدعايه الا ان هواجس الاغتصاب والاوضاع
المعيشيه كانت حاضره في تحركات شعبيه
ونداءات لمنظمات المدنيه اذ قالت انتقادات
السلطه واتهمت بعدم الاقتراط لمطالب الناس
الحقيقيه رساله سياسيه للمسكين بالسلطه
اليوم انه المسار الاخذوه في غياب رؤيا
همم حقيقيه في علاقه بالمساء الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي هو ومصار خطير يوسع من الفقر
يوسع من الهشاشه وبشلق بتداويته على فئات
اجتماعيه عديده وبيش يكون عنوان لنضال
خلال المرحله القادمه تعاني تونس ازمه
الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه منذ سنوات زادتها
الازمه الصحيه ثم عماقتها انعكاساته الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا امر نتج عنه ارتفاع
الاسعار فقدان بعض السلع الاساسيه
تقول الحكومه انها تعمل على تعديل الاوضاع
عبر سلسله اصلاحات اقتصاديه ويقول انصار
الرئيس ان التشكيله برلمان جديد سينجو عنه
استقرار اقتصادي وتعديلات مهمه بينما يرى
اخرون ان الدستور الجديد لا يمنح صلاحيات
نيابيه تسمح للبرلمان بالقيام بهذا الدور
في ظل يعني تكوين وخبره
وكفاءه بعض المترشحين اعتقد سيكون مجلس
النيابي مبتور سيكون مجلس النواب بيغير
قادر على عبد دوره كرافعه من رافعه من
رافعه الثانيه في البلاد يحمل الرئيس قيس
سعيد واذا تفاقم اوضاع التونسيين المعيشيه
لمن حكموا في العشريه السابقه ليس ذلك
فحسب بل عجز الرئيس تحركاته خلال الايام
الاخيره بهدف وضع المسالات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه على سلم اولوياته كما يرى
هذه رساله للعالم القضيه بتاع شعب التونسي
قضيه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
المظاهرات امام المسرح خشبه المسرح المهم
هي القضيه بتاع الشعب الدوسي بسرعه
اما المعارضه فترى ان البرلمان المقبل
سيكون بلا صلاحيات ويتشكل في ظل انهيار
بعض القطاعات الاقتصاديه واستفها
للمديونيه
يبقى الهاجس الاقتصادي هو ما يؤرق
المواطنه التونسي سواء كان مشاركا ام
مقاطعه لهذه الانتخابات وفي الوقت الذي
يؤكد فيه الرئيس قيس سعيد ان القرارات
التي اتخذها تهدف الى اصلاح الاوضاع
المعيشيه تعتبرها المعارضه تفردا بالسلطه
وعجزا عن ايجاد حلول حقيقيه للوضع
الاقتصاديه في البلاد
الجزيره تونس